[Music]
by this
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you something that is
about my culture uh
how i view life and
don't really like to talk about it uh
what i believe in
so today without further ado
i bring you custom statue
from zion art anubis
it's a little bit different we're going
to get into the history of anubis
and we're going to talk about a couple
of other things
well first a lot of times you may see me
start off with welcome right
and that is uh me praising god
that is uh me uh asking god
to uh see everything before me
and to grant me safe passage
in what i'm about to do so it's a
greeting
and it's also a goodbye so that's why i
sign off with that as well
so now that you know that um
let's get into who anubis is
anubis is a lot of y'all think he's
like the god of the dead no the god of
the dead is osiris
before osiris took over that spot anubis
did sit there to
uh watch over the dead uh anubis is a
protector
right and he protects the dead he ushers
them
into the afterlife he is who you see and
who you talk to
on your journey to the boatman
also anubis is a teacher anubis has
taught uh various egyptians
how to embalm he's the god of embalming
the god of preparing and caring for the
body as the body makes its
journey over into the afterlife
cleansing the body
so he taught that to be done and also
anubis is the god of presiding over the
judgment
of your soul as you go to the afterlife
you go to the room of judgment where the
gods watch over you
and your heart is placed on a scale
against a feather now when your heart is
placed on the scale against the feather
if your heart is heavier than a feather
if you carry
a lot of burdens into the afterlife then
you're not granted safe passage into the
afterlife
into the promised land that is anubis
so i know you say oh he has the face of
a jackal he's
he's terrifying no he isn't
um the depiction of that is uh
a lot of metaphysical stuff that we
won't get to on here
but i gave you a brief synopsis of who
he is
and if you want to read a couple of
books uh you can read the
black bible of science uh you can also
read the stolen legacy egyptians
origins of western philosophies you can
watch that
and you can also read the egyptian
mythology
god's goddesses and traditions of
ancient egypt
that will give you a brief and a
very very very good broad view
of uh egyptian mythology and
uh the pantheon of the gods and how the
greeks and stuff like that
work within that to to do certain things
well let's get to the statue i love zion
arts work and zion art uh
work is so fantastic so he reached out
to me when he let me know that he was
doing the gods of egypt line and i told
him i'm the first guy on board
uh make sure that you know he got he
received
my uh payment uh for the commission of
the statute
and i could not say that it didn't go
any better
this statue is phenomenal from the base
to the the structure to the switch outs
to the head to the poles to the paint
applications
honestly i'm not gonna lie i think this
is the best statue he's done
and not because i'm a super fan it's
just because
the paint applications are done so well
on the bones
on the rocks on the base where you see
the hieroglyphs
the uh uh anubis heads
also you see the snake rapture
around the base and the different type
of textures
and then you get to the statue itself
the statue itself you can
see where the metal is where the skin is
where the
wrappings is on anubis
from the gold to the silver to the
bronze
to the anks to the different uh pieces
that's on him now i did wish
that they used real um what is this uh
jade inside these spots where jade can
go
and i might send it to the statue doctor
to see if he can put some jade
emeralds in i mean some jade uh crystals
inside their
hair and also inside the headdress it
comes with
two switch out portraits
the portraits are phenomenally done you
have the jackal face
which is here and
you have his oh
warrior face i guess which is there
and it comes with
a limited edition card so you know the
number that you have
and i have number 14 number lucky 14
and you have anubis and you have
the actual anubis on the side with the
number it's
uh a beautiful card that you can display
next to your statue
it comes with an ankh and a sheath the
sheath
is there uh and the ankh
is there as well uh some people call it
a side
the sheath is cutting grain and and
grass and stuff like that
that's what i believe it's used for i
don't believe it's for cutting down
anyone um in my opinion but
uh anubis has gotten a bad rap over the
years and i don't believe it's necessary
but he is one of the most recognizable
gods of egypt so i believe that he would
definitely be
the first in the line of the gods the
next in the line i believe is horus
and hopefully we can get ahmanra the
most high
the god of all gods above you know the
statue line i can definitely place this
inside my bedroom
which i'm going to do well this is the
part in the video
when i'm going to ask you to like follow
and subscribe
and hit the joy button hit that join
button
you know where that join button is the
join button is right there down at the
bottom
you can hit that join button and you can
see everything that goes on in the realm
you can see lords of gaming.net uh where
we have a ton of opinion writers
you can also see the last word with
loyal cognito and ibontis
you can see all other episodes of kos
and
you can just check out what we do in the
realm when we go to these trade shows
like packs
like e3 and some videos that we have up
there that you didn't get a chance to
see
so please follow us please share please
get that out to everyone else
and also do me a favor check out darth
castlex fridays at 9 00 pm
and also catch me on iron lord's podcast
sundays at 1pm
where we're giving you that pure gaming
news
so check it out see you later and um
that was a a nod to my man lemon oh man
108 dragons
he is the best if you don't know 180
dragons go to his channel
subscribe he has big things coming and
you can check it out
well next week um
i'm going to bring you something super
red hot and atomic stay
collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
you